function and I enjoyed it very much so
today I'm going to my talk is going to
be based on join the work in a long time
collaborator to me high and detection of
space signal segments so the basic
problem not interesting here is very
simple suppose you're have reservations
on our own sequence and most of the
synchronous actually just a pure lies do
you have some more segments of signals
embedded in this sequence and my goal is
to detect these signals so the basic
question is to what extent and how can
we effectively develop what detected
signals the k difference when the user
space signal detection problem is while
here instead of just having single turn
signal the signal actually comes in its
segment so you want to make it take
advantage of the structure in the hope
ladder you can detect a signal pattern
but assuming that you know use your
second spar signal detection problem
with steel because the second water
segment the lens is much smaller than
compared to when the original sequence
so you still have need to do in a
multiple tasking problem of course this
kind of problem naturally arises in many
different applications here I just want
to give you a couple of examples in a
very superficial way so what about one
of our motivating example is this so
called a copy number variation analysis
so the basic idea here is if you look at
a whole genome you are going to say many
changes either due to mutations or
deletion the usual single single
nucleotide polymorphism basically look
at the changes at a single a single base
pair but in this kind of copy number
variation what we are interested in
actually the segment of changes and we
want to find the disagreements and there
are several ways that nowadays you can
do this and keep recording the data you
would observe in a very typical study if
getting the top panel here so what we
have is the x axis basically to the
relative location on a genome divided
into different chromosomes and the y
axis is the larger ratio of the copy
lamb burgers around particular genome
compared with the reference genome so as
you can imagine if you ladies a low
change what are you able to observe
essentially the pure noise when I mean
zero but if you lay is a change what we
are going to say is a significant
different given a ship from zero but of
course the main issue here is if you
just look at at all panels very hard to
say where the signal is whether or not
there is any sacramento structure but if
you do me in to look at a particular
chromosome or even a particular section
of the comments on the bottom
panel shows it's pretty evident you see
in right in the middle like right here
you will have a segment of changes and
here that you can tell the two main
features as I mentioned before first of
all it's not a singleton circular but a
writer stack a segment here the
sacramental in this particular case case
last about two hundred base pairs but
when compared with whole genome this is
very still very short segment and
another example problem is more generic
you could pick a detection problem so
basically idea here is you suppose you
observe a signal can you identify all
the pics in this signal and this
particular data example actually taken
from the so-called ship sick data
analysis really it's a way for
biologists to act and define the so
called transcription factor binding
sites and each of these aside would
correspond to the peak basically end up
in the plot in the top panel of this
figure here and of course we just look
at the top panel you may think leather
the pic really is just a single chance
at a single location but for example if
we do mean to look at a peak right here
you realize actually the peak last for
about 200 positions so again you would
have a segment of changes and this is
very important what it's made out to be
very important for detecting say for
example these sharp peaks because the
signal is strong enough but this is much
more important suppose you have a
relative weaker signal you want to
really share information together by
recognizing the fact that a signal
actually comes in as a cig as a segment
so mathematically how do we formulate
this problem is actually very simple
model here we look at it is so this
basically a single signal plus noise
model suppose your observations are
excise which is again as I mentioned is
a very long sequence suppose the lancet
end here and signal detection problem we
are considering here essentially the
hypothesis testing problem so under law
hypothesis let's law second well also
all the means moving all the way to
million or zeros but under the
alternative just a for simplicity let's
just start with just one segment of
signal so that the basically means Allah
is a segment basically an interval
between 0 and 0 0 between one and n
where you have a signal imperative
turret so here I'm going to represent
this signal that is FN here so you can
think of this FN you essentially the
function defined between 0 and the one I
kind of either stretches or squeeze it
so I
put it in a long sequence and the goal
here of course is to understand to a
dimension before to what extent we can
detect such a signal and very
intuitively you will probably would
realize there are two main determining
factors and the detectability of the
signal why is this amplitude the other
wines do duration its duration just to
give you some idea so let's look at a
very simple exercise here so the second
where I have here is on the right hand
side it's already shape and what I do
here is a very simple simulation study
so I in battery single of signal into a
sequence of Alliance 2048 I embedded I'm
right into in the middle in the middle
section here which lasts about lust
exactly 200 positions so what I have
here is an in the top panel on the
bottom panel essentially is the
difference of amplitude well of course
the second or actually I highlighted
here using is very box if I don't join
us rider box it's much harder to say
whether or not that is a signal in the
top panel but in the bottom panel by
increased amplitude it becomes much
easier to find any signal same in a
story for the duration again I if I
input while in solitary signal into the
middle of this this sequence the
difference between the top 1 i'm the
bottom line to the top one not only for
100 position what bottom one master 500
position again as you can tell it's much
easier to say let Allah is a signal in
the bottom panel so of course this gives
us some intuition that when the
amplitude of signals its larger is
easier to detect when the duration is
longer is also easier to detect but
whatever interesting is exactly what
kind of laser is the relationship
between the two so we can detect the
signal and it turns out it depends on
how much you'll know about a signal so
in this particular case we look at the
three different situations the first
situation is suppose you'll know the
shape of the signal so don't know the
amplitude you don't know your location
but you'll know exactly what kind of
shape please take in your hat the second
situation is suppose we're not laughing
about the signal we don't know the
sheriff we don't know anything about it
about a signal and the third one is
perhaps more realistic suppose we have a
little bit quantitative qualitative
information about the signal how much
better come with you so let's start with
a simple this one started in the
situation
if we're low exactly the shape of the
signal so basically least taken on FN
here it's just a constant multiplied by
a lone template f0 here and the most
well studied the case actually there
have been some study of this particular
setting essentially while probably
starting with ariel castro in 2004 so
they look at the case supposedly 70 is
just a constant so suppose you have a
constant signal how do you detect the
signal and then let's study the
so-called scan statistics basically the
likelihood ratio test in this case and
of course there is nothing special about
the constant signal you can naturally
extend the layer result into any
arbitrary 12-person you have some
regularity conditions for sure so you
can extend the lease to more general
loan templates so basically idea here is
if you look at a particular window
suppose I want to ask myself a question
if there is a signal between 18 and a PN
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
look at the way to the average of your
observation in that window because the
main reasons because I lo the shape of
the signal if ladies in the other signal
I want to choose a weight accordingly
basically reflecting your knowledge of
the two signal I look at that is
weighted average and of course this is
only for one segment one window here and
I move across all possible or candidate
segments so for each segment I ask
myself a question if you ladies a signal
signal a lot and I'll take the maximum
of all these statistics and the reject
allow hypothesis of course if this if
this maximum it goes beyond a certain
threshold and turns out you can show
indeed if you choose your cutoff point
without critical value appropriately
basically is over the order of square
root square square root of log n now you
can't detect any signal let's satisfy
this condition so basically this sign
implies i have larger than or equal to
up to a constant factor here so the
square amplitude is going video is going
to be greater than or equal to ab to a
constant over the order basically is
logging over the end so log n n is the
original ines over the original sequence
and DN is the length of your tooth of
the real signal and I just one who
should demonstrate a little bit on how
this really works so suppose again so
this is the this is the figure actually
I should
before so now if i don't all-around a
box probably you'll find it's a little
bit harder to say whether or not a laser
signal a lot so I do I look at a
different window so I look at us in well
actually I in the in the simulation I
didn't many different window sizes but
here just for you to tration I focus on
three different window sizes so this one
is 220 this one is 100 this one is a 500
so what I do is I slider this window for
each window I calculate that this is
likely hood ratio statistics and these
are the plots of these statistics and
one thing I want to emphasize here is
our task the procedure essentially take
the maximum of all these test statistics
and if you look at it just these three
panels what I can tell you is from if
you look at the window of size 20 was
windows sighs 500 which of course is
different from the truth in this case
you want to be able to detect the signal
but if you have the right size here not
only you are able to detect the signal
you can locate exactly where the signal
is by taking the maximum of audio track
record racial characteristics and it
turns out when a little bit of
calculation you can also show this would
be the best you can do in a sense latch
you can if the signal really has an
amplitude satisfy this condition known
as i mentioned likelihood ratio test
statistics can achieve consists in the
detection meaning that if you some other
type one error and have to air it goes
to zero and the other hand the following
in the language of Ariel Castro at all
if the amplitude of signal actually is
smaller than where you go to this order
while actually up to a constant here
smaller than where you could equal to
lace and enhanced will be powerless so
basically lays low detection scheme that
would be able to detect such a weak
signal so I one thing what one issue I
want to emphasize here is formally
straight actually you can immediately
say the the benefit of recognizing the
fact that a signal comes in segments
because if you only have one single
thing singular the detection is only
impossible if you see a very large
observation how large basically wanted
either observation to be over order log
n but if your signal really is a lot of
spots actually go to over a long region
say for example the ends of the order of
the whole sequence is just a fraction of
a sequence detection is possible if you
have even very awake a second
so again as I mentioned this is the
perhaps the simplest of the case well we
assume that you will know the shape of
the signal and in most practical cases
that's probably such information problem
is not available so in the other end of
the spectrum when we will be interested
in here is well what happens thank you
you can yes so what would happen if we
don't know anything about a signal so
the signal can be of any shape I don't
have any prior knowledge clearly you can
no longer do the play the same game as
before because it is what way did it
before essentially is averaging out to
your observation in a particular window
now if you don't know anything about a
second or the signal could be positive
could it be lagging if you're just do an
average you were averaged out of signal
turns out a very simple trick well
essentially solve this problem so what
we do is instead of looking at the
average directly on your region of the
original observation r square i take a
square of all the original observations
and an average name out but one thing
you gave gotta pay attention to it
because i have laws when you square you
have this sentence so essentially i
subtract the mean when you just have
pure lloyds and an averaging out another
issue i want to emphasize here is
instead of normalizing just using the
lines of the signal you also want to
account for multiplicity so here is this
factor of log n comes into play and the
Lenni essentially play the same game I
look at all candidate windows for each
window I calculate that is quadratic
test statistics and then I look at the
maximum if the maximum is greater than
the critical value I'm going to say
laser signal and particularly the signal
is located at the maximum point yes
well the intuition is just our
domination because your signal can be
positive on live here because just one
sign you'll probably will think about it
just average man and the main difficulty
of the original image if you have
positive sign Allah gives you will
average out of a saving up I do ask
where you will decay to the second
century
well I'm assuming that you don't know
anything about a solution so I'm like in
previous one your lower back any other
questions ok so again yes
that must you are assuming that a signal
just environmental but I'm good
any other question ok so again we are
just the focusing on one singular
segment and if you don't know anything
about a signal you do this kind of
quadratic a type of statistics and you
can also show again you choose the
critical value to be of the order of
square root of log n then you will be
able to detect any signal if its
amplitude it's greater length allows the
sum of two things the first thing is
exactly the same as we've seen before
for signals where you'll know the ship
the second thing is extra actually be
suggested the alternative way of writing
the following thing basically is whether
or not low in the inflow in the shape of
the of the signal helps you really
depends on how long your signal is and
of course this is just in terms of rate
rotting in terms of constant in terms of
constant and certainly no initiation
helped a lot but in terms of the rate
they actually kill interesting regimes
for short signals you still have
detection at the rate essentially login
/ d but if along the signals all of a
sudden you need to take a square root
which means you are going to ask for
much stronger signal so that you can be
detected and you can also show this
indeed is the optimal rate in that any
other detection scheme would become
powerless if the amplitude is of order a
while the smaller than or equal to this
value here and the most difficult case
well for those who study this kind of
minimax lower bound stuff you want to
know exactly what kind of signal is the
most most difficult to detect the most
difficult signal to detect essentially
is your second the latter flip signs
very often so basically is random plus
or minus this M particular here and I
wanted to again emphasize a little bit
about the comparison between the case
when we load the shape and well you
don't have any information about the
shape so again as I mentioned as far as
the rate is concerned for shorter
signals you don't lose much by water
know in the ship but for longer signals
low in the shape really helps you
tremendously and just to again give you
a little bit of intuition and how these
two situations come here with each other
again a look at this example we've seen
before I have this signal really
highlighted he is right a box here so
the red dots is
the case when the loader signal you do
scan whinnies linea statistics and the
black ones correspond to the quadratic a
type of Statistics when you don't know
anything about a signal as scale the two
so they have the same critical value and
a critical value with a corresponding to
this horizontal gray line here so a lot
of surprising is we were seen before if
you load the shape of the signal you
will be able to tell that a second is
right here as you can hear this is very
good identification where the signal is
but if you don't know the shape of the
signal you were just a few failed to
identify the signal because this is just
below the threshold so what this tells
us is exactly loading the info in the
shape of the signal really can help you
in situations like less tude attack of
the signal but a very large real
question here is how much does it take
for us to fill in the gap because in
practice is probably too much to ask to
select with low exactly the shape but
maybe we don't just but on the other
hand it's probably a little bit too
pessimistic to say that we don't have
any information about the signal and it
turns out if you'll know a little bit
qualitatively about a signal it can help
you a long way and in particular we'll
look at this specific situation suppose
you'll know the signal has some sort of
smoother lives and it is described the
summaries are here we use the whole
class essentially what we are looking at
is suppose you'll know a little bit
about your signal essentially is your
signal should come from a whole job or
in order artha and here naturally there
are two questions the first one is in
this case what's the optimal detection
rate the second one is how do we devise
an effective tool of finding or taking
advantage of the smoothest and
imperative to hack the signal and turns
out we have all the main ingredients
already in the previous two cases but
here we need to combine them a little
bit the main intuition here is here we
scan in a case when we load a signal we
do some sort of linear statistics for
scan if you don't know the signal you do
quadratic statistics and the linea
statistical turns out to be very good
suppose your signal that's what a change
you very much when respect to your
information about a signal but a
quadratic aesthetic is very useful
suppose your second will change too
very quickly and you want to combine
these two together well before we talk
about a detailed details about this I
want to just kind of show you this
diagram essentially demonstrate what
kind of main detection rates what kind
of main result in terms of optimal
detection rate we would obtain turns out
is a very peculiar setting here so what
we have seen here well what I pro here
is the x axis is the lines of the signal
taken well scared win log n so basically
you kind of think of the length of the
signal is a log in to some polynomial
and a disability this would be the
degree of the polynomial same thing I
locate the school look look at the
amplitude of the signal if I look at the
list there is a polynomial of log n here
this would be the degree of the
polynomial so from our previous
discussion when low light if you load
the shape of the signal basically
detection region is anywhere above this
diagonal so including all associated
areas and we'll also look at a situation
when you don't have any information
about a signal and the ladder will
correspond to essentially true this
because the lateral area shaded in red
so this is the area where you can track
the signal even without any information
about the shape so what happens if you
have a little bit of smoothness and
turns out there are two different
situations here I just give you a cue
example why I suppose I'll oh it's
smooth inner to the signal comes from
the whole class of order 1 lanisa would
be again let's cause a quadrilateral
area shaded in both red yellow and blue
but if it's from a higher class when
orders say in this particular example
one faiths all of a sudden this becomes
essentially a pentagon essentially would
be the area corresponding to both the
red shaded region and the yellow shaded
region actually this is a long convex
Pentagon here you have a king here so
this is basically the main kind of a
summary of the main result we would get
now let's talk a little bit more detail
on exactly what's the nature of this
diagram here let's start with the
question how do we did hack the signal
by taking advantage of the Sudanese the
strategy as i mentioned actually is very
simple we try to combine the idea of
linear statistics and the quadratic
statistics so to start off
what we are going to do is we are going
to suppose we are interested in knowing
whether or not Holly is a signal between
a and B n so I will start off by
dividing this year this interval into
several pings and within each pin
because of smoothness the second one is
going to be more or less stable so now
do average win in the pink so this is
how I end up when these averages with
her while Jeff cause you're scaring a
little bit so they can have some sort of
more or less normal distribution when
with no merit with some constant
variance and 11 what I do is across
things because the low signal could
change very dramatically so what we want
to do is we want to kind of combine all
this information together using the
quadratic type of statistics I discussed
earlier and again this is exactly the
same just the best same as before it's
just now instead of looking at the
original data and looking at the average
over all the pings I put all of them
together again this would be my evidence
for why do a lotta laser signal between
a and B n then I look at all candidate
segments I take the maximum and I use
the same church holding narrow as we've
seen before and then we can detect the
signal but of course there's one big
piece missing here how many beings
should we divide it is raging in queue
and this turns out to be a little bit
sophisticated and this is where the king
we've seen in the previous diagram comes
into play it turns out early the
translation really will we will look at
a signal data from a whole job or it
depends on the order is greater than
one-quarter was smaller than one-quarter
and of course if you think about the
whole job or if this order is very close
to zero basically means your signal is
more or less like a distress signal and
if a far bigger of course gets smoother
and smoother and let's start with a
situation when alpha is greater than or
equal to one-quarter layer you century
well is you essentially illustrated by
this sorry the black line here let us
three regions the first one is supposed
the lines of a second the window you're
looking at is very short shorty in that
the lens is actually smaller than or
equal to log n basically in this case
you don't do any meaning so you just do
this quadratic attack which is a lot of
surprising because as well
thing we will do this kind of quadratics
type of scanning basically you don't
lose in terms of rate of detection and
you don't lose any information and the
interesting part actually happens in the
middle so at one end is your lines is
log n the other end is logging up to
order of 2 alpha plus 1 in this area
forget about how long it is i'm always
going to divide it into beings of size
log N and the leg if the signal is even
longer now I want to take into account
length of the signal so the good news
here is foremost a tradition for most of
examples i'm going to look at actually
lens is more or less for into this
category and it is tells us we don't
need to worry too much about how to
choose the pink size pleaseguy divide
everything into bins of large size over
again and in the case when after the
smaller than one-quarter ten certainly
is one more change here so basically you
go up just like in the case when you
have alpha greater than or equal to
one-quarter and the land will take this
fix the size of log in but then the last
one actually is the same i will go up by
the land at some point I'm going to just
stay with DM and this is not surprising
leader so basically this what this means
is when a signal is long enough how long
basically if your signal it's over this
order again what I'm going to do is I'm
not going to do bidding at all so I'm
going to just do individual quadratic
pastor statistics when this choice over
the paintings are you can identify the
rate of detection using this particular
detector what kind of signals can get
attacked again of course not
surprisingly we will have essentially
two different regimes depending on how
big you are our fighters to order is if
the order is greater than or equal to
one-quarter you have two phases not
surprisingly so you have a change
essentially when your signal is more
it's a short then you achieve the same
rate of detection as if you load the
shape of the signal but I want you to
draw a little bit of comparison when the
previous setting we will see we don't
have any information about a signal the
transition occurs at the log N and if
you have smoother is the translation
occurs analog end up to 2 alpha plus 1
so the smaller the signal is
were able to push actually the range a
little bit of further so if the signal
is really smooth what i can do is i can
achieve the same same type of rate of
detection and i look even by located a
little bit longer signals and the window
sticker is kind of a longer then you end
up with a rate that the kind of
compounding both things why is the
smoothness and the other one is
basically the login factor accounts for
the fact we're looking at multiple
second multiple segments when alpha is
smaller than one quarter this is exactly
why we see a little bit of king here so
basically i would have three different
regimes this area this area in this area
so that would correspond to two
different transitions just like when
alpha is greater than one quarter for
sure signal I don't lose the in terms of
rate of detection in the middle heart
I'm going to again I low in that your
signal is a smooth although the
smoothness actually is very weak it's
smaller than one quarter but when your
signal is very long there's no benefit
of knowing that your signal is smooth
essentially you end up on the same type
of rate of detection as if you don't
know anything about a signal and this
property is a little bit of surprising
because the main reasons you'll know a
little bit of smoothness and you would
expect for longer signals you should be
able to take advantage of that but turns
out that the main the main issue here is
because your smoothness is so weak and
for very long signals taking advantage
of such smooth lives becomes more
difficult particularly when we take into
account that you are doing this kind of
multiple comparison so again just to
demonstrate a little bit how much does
be need help again I look at this this
example if you are using many times here
we have a signal here and it just as
before I have this right adults probably
the real hard to say this is the case
suppose you load the shape of the signal
so you will use this to detect it and
then the black one of course is company
the overlay here but just if you
remember from previous discussion so the
red the red adults would exceeded the
threshold in line by identifying what
signal is the black one where you don't
assume you'll know anything about a
signal which is just below the threshold
in now so you only be able to detect a
second
now suppose down low the signal is
smooth just as before as i mentioned i'm
going to choose a ping size which is
just log n in this case is seven so i
look at this i bring everything into set
well and for each window I big name by
size seven and again we need to being
average them out and a clasping I'm
going to do this kind of quadratic types
of statistics and at house of services
is giving these green dots and as you
can tell here even with a little bit of
information about the smoothness welcome
to achieve almost the same lab of
detection in this particular example and
this is what we often observed in
practice a little bit of beaming really
helps a lot so so if I've been talking
about essentially three different
settings of detecting just one single
one single signal segment basically is
the case you'll know the shape of the
signal the case you don't know anything
about it and they learn the case you'll
know the signal is smooth but one thing
one question you may have particularly
regarding the last two wires you have
the truth is choose the spinning size
condom carefully if you really want to
have a very company the characteristics
you want to choose the spinning sides
according to the knowledge of alpha and
of course in practice you know how many
times differentiable was sick in New is
but tennis out how this is a lot of
bigger problem and what you can do is
you can achieve that reputation by doing
this so called a multiscale scan so what
you do is well it's a lot of [ __ ]
basically this is what happens suppose
our gang I have this window I want to
know if laser signal if I low the signal
is alpha times differentiable I'm going
to use the types of statistics i
introduced before if you don't know how
many times differentiable it is i simply
take a maximum over all these possible
alphas and of course you will think of
all it's taking over or offers how do
you computer is what turns out because
of this critter nature of the sequence
it's actually not another complicated
essentially i just depending everything
in a different sizes and you apply the
same type of idea located average with a
big look at the quadratic statistics and
it essentially is kind of like you are
looking at essentially or what are these
correspond to is i have the original
sequence what i'm going to do is I'm
going to do scan of quadratic statistics
then I'm going to bring everything in
your size of two I do this kind of
quadratic statistics again are being
everything in the size of three I do it
again actually in practice you don't
even need it to do two three four five
you can have a factor here and then you
look at the maximum of all these
different test statistics and again you
can show indeed if your couch enter
exactly at the level screen would have
log n you can detect the signal we're
not annoying how smooth the second row
is so this is a one practical issue and
another practical issue actually also
rising in the previous blog in one of
the questions before basically is how do
we handle multiple segments actually the
locations are really complicated here
but the idea is very simple so basically
this is what we do we first start by
look having a collection of all can you
later intervals know what I'm going to
do is I'm going to do a scan over all
these intervals computing the likelihood
by laser signal in any one of these
these segments and I take the maximum
one if at the maximum lines below the
shush hold of course reading indicates
there's no signal at all but if the
maximum is greater than that i'm going
to look at a subset of all lays whose
likelihood ratios of course casual
statistics above the threshold and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take the
largest away once you take the largest
one one thing you need to pay attention
to is all these segments Canada segments
they kind of overlap with each other so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take out from the start on Canada
segments or rows that overlap when the
one identified and this makes sense
because the other ones may still show up
simply because it may overlap when it to
signal so after I do that I do my scan
again I find the last one are you
traitor list until at the end you want
to find any significant segment and this
would be my collection of signal
sacraments and you can ensure under
appropriate conditions this procedure
indeed can deduct all the signal
segments let are detectable in the sense
that as I discussed before for single
single segments because if the amplitude
is too small you want to be able to
detect it but if you use this scheme you
can do tackle all those detectable
detectable signal segments and the
collection actually consists in the in
the sense that or the dog attack while
the identify the segments would be
exactly the segments you want to look at
where the signals are so I'm not sure if
I'm q Quakers so anyway so this is just
a kind of quick summary of what I
discussed it earlier so basically is our
demonstrated here detecting [ __ ]
enough segments is common in many
applications and it's very important to
recognize it is because of course the
actually of space signals has reserved
received a lot of attention race in the
years but the main difficulty when
detecting generic response signal says
you really have to observe something
that's really large for you to be able
to say that ur there is a signal here if
the signals comes in segments it's very
important that either we share
information taking taking into account
the fact that they are coming into
segments and share information within
the segment and this way this can help
us better identify the signal is you can
tell here even if the information that
you can share is very weak like in the
case we don't know anything about the
signal so basically the the only thing
you wouldn't know is just lay there
contribute sites that have signal but
you don't have any other information
even in other case they are ways you can
share information across sites within
the segment so you can have a good
detection and the way the optimal
detection can be achieved essentially is
our mission here basically using the
idea of scanning and a scanning using
water type of statistics twist again
heavily depends on how much knowledge
you have about a signal so again as I
mentioned here there are too many
ingredients why is the to scan using
this type of linear statistics which is
very useful in the case suppose you load
the shape of the signal and then there's
this kind of quadratic a type of
statistics which allows you to
accommodate the case when the signal
actually changes very frequently and you
can combine both to take advantage of
possible smoothness and actually there
are other six items you can look at
other type of different shapes and
things this kind of prior information
oftentimes can help can go along
way and also as I mentioned the two
possible extensions that are maybe a
practical interest why is suppose you
are down low the degree of smoothness
you can achieve adaptation by doing this
multi multi scale scan the other one is
you can modify the procedure a little
bit for you to identify all the possible
signal segments and when it shall stop
if you have any questions that you have
yes
so what he was asking is what happens if
you use some sort of waiver it with a
procedure to achieve adaptation actually
there are two issues here why is the
difference between estimation and
testing the rating of a thing here
actually is bad on an estimation the
adaptation without the most study for
waiver it actually concerned suing
estimation fort asking after you can be
better there are signals you cannot
estimate but you can't detect and so
well as in terms of adaptation typically
will you look at a long time and
aggression when you try to achieve
adaptation we need to pay your price
which is gone into action modern factor
and here support walk but surprisingly
interesting Adonia diplomatic ties the
main Raven is that applies is or
comparing the multiple testing factor
mattifies actually smaller so turns out
all the price willing to pay is rioting
in the market
so the question really is the
relationship when the detection rates we
have here compared with what it is that
has done so basically what is the task
is to locate a situation basically long
time measuring smoothing Saturn suppose
we have a signal between zero and one
which is similar function how were kind
of test whether or not the function 20 a
lot and the basically if you are fit
well follow the question medial in this
kind of calculation this is kind of like
well maybe you maybe i should say this
so to to do a fair comparison probable
wish to look at a situation suppose the
way Louis action where the signal is
that will be exactly what the problem
instant looking at and iterate the
typical to get regardless of the
smoothness index so there's no
transition when alpha equals to one
quarter you always get a district which
is DN up to minus 45 divided by one plus
four other and the other k differences
because you want to account for multiple
testing and what would happen is one we
have this transition is a far equals to
one quarter to the price you'll pay for
multiple testing is no longer log n by
log n up to some factor that's actually
smaller than one one half
it's
do you say that again so I couldn't hear
you
e
oh yes actually this is exactly what we
talked about it towards the very end of
course I hired some of a walk I didn't
discuss much of their details so
basically if you have multiple signals
actually you do to some condition for
you to be able to tell them up hot
because you don't have much assumption
about a signal you may very well have
less taking the ladder goes up go back
to zero and then go up again so in this
case it's not identifiable you can do or
say reduces once again or to signal so
basically what would do what what people
would do in practice is whatever why
when you say like the signal the lines
of the signal is relatively short one
compared in the inter distance between
signals in other case what you can do is
buy just the kind of doing this can take
out all these intervals that overlaps
with whatever identified then do scan
again just by using this iterative
procedure you can identify all the
signal segments
no you won't the main reason is because
in Justice Scalia for one interval you
already apply the idiom bar because
having two intervals were having whining
intervals again you are just scanning
through all of them and the factories
variety well the price you are paying
for scanning multiple segments is
already reflected